Accueillir
Bonjour, qui comprend, nous sommes toutes des femmes ici
Le salon n'ouvre pas la tente, c'est usé et lent, soeur
Qu'est-ce que tu as à voir avec la chirurgie maxillo-faciale, tu es le deuxième que je veux
Je termine pour tout le monde
[musique]
Dieu est grand, il l'entend si tu coupes de mauvais cheveux, je le jure
Ne le regarde pas
Comment veux-tu te coiffer ?
Ma sœur, tu ne trouveras rien de plus grand que ce salon
Celui qui couche avec le scorpion, Dieu est son épouse, pas toi
je ne veux pas le dire
Je me demande ce qui s'est passé dehors, tu m'as promis que tu ouvrirais
Une nouvelle page, mais souviens-toi et souviens-toi, Dab, sérieusement
Je t'aime, que veulent-ils pour libérer ce lion ?
Le lion veut effacer le vert et le sec
Laisse ce qui se passe dehors, viens finir
Tu n'aimes plus ce que ton amant a
Al-Sarsari : Savez-vous combien d'ânes sont abattus pour lui ?
Ce jour c'est l'Aïd avec toutes sortes de glaces sauf de
Kaz Mutaa, désolé mes sœurs, on s'est un peu emportées
Dès que vous l'aimez, vous êtes assis ici
[musique]
Amusons-nous. Qu'en pensez-vous? Laissez-les vous offrir des bonbons
Je le jure devant Dieu, tu ne sors pas avec un éclair ?
Que Dieu fasse descendre sur vous ses bénédictions et vous porter
Voler